vous ça ne vous fait pas peur ce genre
de choses alors absolument aucune phrase
j'ai jamais vu de violence il y a pas de
raison d'avoir peur
les rêves party s'est faite clandestine
et gratuites défaites improviser qui
sortent de terre comme des champignons
tous sont là pour une seule chose
écoutez de la techno loin de tout
système commercial
[Musique]
le monde des rêveurs se veut libertaire
presque anarchiste et c'est justement ce
qui dérange car en cas de problème il
est difficile de trouver un responsable
pour vivre heureux vivons caché c'était
leur devise repère de drogués pour la
police concert barbares pour les parents
depuis les années 80 les rêves vivaient
dans la clandestinité mais peu à peu
elle sorte de l'ombre
cela n'ont pas eu à éviter les barrages
de CRS et ont acheté leur billet dans
les grands magasins vous pouvez
l'appeler rêve au festival techno c'est
légal et ça a des avantages
[Musique]
spéciaux et tout vraiment là dessus moi
je trouve quand c'est organisé il y a
beaucoup plus de choses mais il a fallu
se battre pour en arriver là l'an
dernier dimension frise l'interdiction
préfectorale du coup ils se sont lancés
dans le lobbying avec des soutiens très
efficaces
je suis allé voir Jean-Pierre
Chevènement accompagné
d'organisateurs de rêve et de concerts
techno pour lui expliquer qu'il n'était
pas normal que cette musique nouvelle
Pacifique
respectueux soit l'objet d'une telle
censure ou de telle tracasserie et je
crois que le ministre de l'Intérieur a
compris et qui se prépare à donner
directives aux administrations pour
faciliter l'organisation de concert et
le rêve
dans l'opinion aussi on sent un
frémissement un nouveau public
les gens sont calmes
ils fument leurs joint dans leur coin et
puis tout va bien
oui ça ne vous fait pas peur ce genre de
choses alors absolument aucune preuve
j'ai jamais vu de violence alors il y a
pas de raison d'avoir peur
la techno envoie de reconnaissance
officielle il serait temps car ailleurs
c'est déjà fait les DJ français
connaissent un succès planétaire et la
culture techno est devenue une référence
[Musique]
si le sifflet est devenu le joujou
emblématique des amateurs de techno ce
n'est peut-être pas pour rien c'est
assez souvent à l'extérieur des rêves on
entend d'autres sifflets moins
pacifiques cela dispersion musclée d'une
soirée à Lille une soirée qui n'avait
pas été autorisée quelques dizaines de
jeunes en garde à vue et une prise de
drogue insignifiante deux sachets
d'herbes pour 300 personnes sur le site
plutôt sage les gamins
[Musique]
ce soir qui devait qui était programmé
au Carrousel du Louvre donc qui n'est
pas autorisé sur Radio FG sont
régulièrement annoncés les soirées les
plus remuant tous les plus branchés ce
weekend là trois des plus importantes
avaient été annulées presque la routine
bonsoir les petits malheureusement au
niveau des au niveau des soirées techno
il y a toujours ce cet énorme problème
d'autorisation qui sont donnés au
dernier moment et
jusqu'au dernier moment c'est pas en
fait si la fête aura lieu ou pas quoi
j'ai une soirée qui
vaut un million et demi de francs et à
dépend de barre de chaises de 35 cm de
profondeur cette soirée réagissent c'est
presque un cas d'école une commission de
sécurité exige avant l'ouverture des
portes que soit installée des centaines
de chaises rivés au sol absurdes puisque
c'est une soirée dansante mais la
Commission en avait le droit une fois
les chaises posées la soirée a pu avoir
lieu moralité même avec un dossier bien
ficelé on s'expose à des aventures
dignes de Kafka une rêve petit géante
qui ressemble à si méprendre à un petit
Woodstock toile de tente feu de camp
vendeur ambulant un rassemblement qui
provoque l'étonnement des riverains
curiosité c'est vrai qu'on a des enfants
donc c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
s'aventurer parce qu'on nous a dit que
c'était assez dangereux mais c'est
irréel il faut vraiment y aller pour
croire quoi c'est très bruyant et que ça
risque de faire
et que ça nous choque mais en fait si
vous voulez qu'on fasse on peut pas de
toute façon
ils nous ont dit bonjour là
c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui prennent
la drogue il y a là mais bon
elle est éteint elle vend pas de la
drogue
l'alcool c'est la pire
l'état subventionne des associations
comme technoplus l'objectif est d'offrir
un lieu de repos d'écoute et de conseils
ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire avec quoi il ne faut pas mélanger
donc voilà ça c'est c'est informatif
objectif le Teknival c'est finalement
déroulé en bonne coopération avec les
services de l'État un bon signe
peut-être pour l'avenir nous ont donné
de l'eau nous ont donné des poubelles et
ça paraît peu mais ça nous a bien rendu
service le terrain est vachement propre
par rapport à d'autres soirées
la recette pour réussir une fripe partie
c'est le secret jusqu'au dernier moment
personne ne doit connaître le lieu de la
fête résultat les rêves ça commence
souvent sur une aire d'autoroute vous
savez où ça se passe si j'ai tout mis au
compris ça doit être en direction de
Pacy-sur-Eure ça doit être ça
et ses amis tournent dans le secteur
depuis près d'une heure et demie
principale sujet de conversation le
fameux amendement Mariani c'est un peu
trop une introduction de l'État dans la
vie privée des gens saisir le son c'est
franchement c'est le début de tout
bientôt il saisiront nos maisons nos
femmes aussi peut-être qu'ils y sont
mais non honnêtement nous on est déjà
civilisés on essaye de ranger de plus en
plus les gens font pas c'est le message
deux heures du matin c'est presque
l'embouteillage sur la départementale 16
au nord de Dreux et surprise aucun
gendarme aucun policier à l'arrivée
comme si les forces de l'ordre avaient
reçu des consignes de clémente la
fripartie peut donc commencer dans un
climat que les organisateurs ont voulu
bon enfant l'amendement Mariani
prévoyait l'obligation de déclaration
préalable de toute rave Homère ou au
préfet ainsi que la saisie du matériel
sonore en cas d'infraction des
dispositions sur lesquelles les députés
socialistes ont vite changé de discours
depuis 6 ans le pouvoir politique a
toujours refusé de parler avec le
mouvement techno et d'un seul coup ils
sont à la recherche d'un dialogue et
comme il y a un dialogue et qu'en face
d'eux ils ont affaire à des jeunes qui
ont des choses à dire des revendications
et un art à faire vivre et bien il
commence à réfléchir
[Musique]